hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today I'm going to talk about the multis
language multis is a unique and
interesting language because it is a
semitic language with a twist it is the
only semitic language that is an
official language of the European Union
it is spoken by around five hundred and
twenty thousand people mostly on the
island nation of Malta which is an
island in the Mediterranean Sea not far
from Sicily and not far from Tunisia and
Libya in North Africa some people claim
that Maltese is a descendant of the
ancient Phoenician language but actually
there's no linguistic evidence for this
Maltese is a descendant of a dialect of
Arabic called ciccolo Arabic or Sicilian
Arabic but it has diverged quite a lot
from Arabic over the last thousand years
or so and has now become its own
language the syntax and grammar of
Maltese remains Arabic and about a third
of the vocabulary is still Arabic and
that includes most of the grammatical
function words as well as a lot of the
most basic vocabulary about half of the
vocabulary is from Italian or Sicilian
and the remaining vocabulary is mostly
from English and French it's still
considered a Semitic language because of
its Arabic origin and because of its
structure but if you take into account
all of the foreign loan words especially
the Romance loanwords then it's
essentially a hybrid language kind of
like a Semitic romance hybrid so how did
this interesting mix of influences come
together to create Maltese well it's
because of its history of course the
Fatimid Caliphate which covered much of
North Africa conquered Sicily at the end
of the ninth century and brought their
Maghrebi or North African dialect of
Arabic with them then in 10:49 seee
Arabic speaking Muslim settlers from
Sicily arrived in Malta which is only
about 200 kilometers away and began to
establish communities there in the year
1091 C II the Normans who were
Christians from Normandy and present-day
France had defeated the Arabs and taken
hold of Sicily and then began taking
hold of Malta - under Norman rule more
settlers from Sicily began arriving in
Malta and bringing their language with
them even though the Normans were
Christian the population of Sicily was
still a mixture of Christians and
Muslims who spoke Arabic alongside this
Cillian language after the decline of
Norman rule the new regime in Sicily
expelled all of the Muslims from Sicily
and from Malta as well this was a very
significant event because it essentially
cut off the SICU low Arabic dialect from
the Muslim arabic-speaking world and it
also cut it off from the classical
Arabic language in other Arabic speaking
lands the Quran remains a conservative
force that prevented the dialects from
changing too much over time but in Malta
that conservative force was no longer
connected to the dialect so the dialect
was free to drift off in its own
direction and become a new language
ciccolo Arabic died out in Sicily but it
continued to be used and evolve in Malta
Malta remained part of the kingdom of
Sicily for several hundred years which
brought lots of Sicilian vocabulary into
the language the island was then
controlled by a string of rulers who
influenced the developing Maltese
language one of the most significant
regimes to rule Malta was the Knights
Hospitaller of Saint John a powerful
order of knights that assisted and
protected Christian pilgrims on their
way to the Holy Land they were given the
island of Malta in 1530 as an outpost to
help prevent an Ottoman invasion of Rome
from the south they made Italian the
official language of the island and it
remained the official language until
1934 this resulted in a large amount of
Italian vocabulary entering the language
there was also a period of two years
when Malta was under French rule and
just from those two years quite a bit of
French vocabulary entered the language -
and the island was a British
protectorate from 1800 to 1956 and of
course that led to the adoption of lots
of English words into Maltese so Maltese
is essentially an Arabic dialect that
has become latinized and to some extent
anglicized so how similar is it to
Arabic today well if you know Arabic and
you try to read some Maltese you will
quickly realize that it's basically
Arabic in structure but you will also
see a lot of foreign vocabulary mostly
Romance vocabulary it is most similar to
the Maghreb dialects of Arabic meaning
the dialects of Morocco Algeria and
Tunisia especially the Tunisian dialect
a lot of Tunisians claim that they can
quite easily understand Maltese that
could be because Tunisian Arabic itself
has quite a few Italian loanwords
and I also understand that a lot of
Tunisians can understand standard
Italian so if they speak Tunisian Arabic
and Italian then they can quite easily
understand Maltese lots of people say
that if you know
Arabic dialect quite well and if you
also know Italian then reading Maltese
won't be much of a problem and with some
adjustment you can also learn to
understand it fairly easily
that doesn't mean you could speak proper
Maltese but maybe you could use your
Arabic and your Italian and sort of pack
a conversation in a new pidgin language
so let's look at a couple examples
sentences of Maltese so this sentence
here is an example of one that's mostly
Arabic by the way I've never learned to
speak Maltese so forgive my
pronunciation LJ Pune and ooh-la-la
koala paparazzi Anita dunya Bok min mia
situation million tera suna now I
understood this sentence almost
perfectly and it's basically all Arabic
the first word ill Japan that's Japan on
do that has a Lhasa that's the tenth a
lock bar that's the biggest paparazzi
Oni
that's not Arabic that's that looks like
an Italian loan word to me
tad dunya so that's in the world the
octave mean that means with more than
and then there's the Arabic number mia
c200 chalene and then there's million
which is million in Arabic - and then
Pettus una which is not Arabic but I
guess that's from Italian or Sicilian
but sometimes you see sentences with a
lot more loan words particularly Italian
here's another sentence you reform a
filmer glad Sione on that include ele
print cheap you toss solid Arietta so
this sentence means migration reform
must include the principle of solidarity
this one has a lot of long words de
forma that's not an Arabic word that's a
long word phil mcgraw Sione feel that
part is Arabic but make it at Sione that
is a long word anda that part is
interesting because this is an Arabic
word that means has but in this case
it's being used to mean has to or must
and it's not used that way in Arabic so
the function of this word has become
somewhat adapted in the Maltese language
the next words include e that's include
but that the T links back to the
previous vowel that's an element of
Arabic syntax the next word print sheep
you so that's obviously principle but
that's not an Arabic word that's a loan
word and tasseled Arrieta
again that's the Arabic definite article
and the T is linking back to the
previous vowel and Soledad Yetta that's
solidarity and that's not an Arabic word
either so you can see a lot of sentences
like this in Maltese often if you know
Arabic you'll recognize the structure
but then a lot of the words are not
Arabic for me personally I know that
with my past study of Arabic and with my
flu
in English and my recent basic knowledge
of Italian I can take a stab at reading
Maltese and I can understand a fair bit
of it but not all of it when I hear
spoken Maltese I don't really understand
it but I can pick out some individual
Arabic and Italian and English words but
I imagine that as my Italian improves
I'll be able to understand a bit more of
it and if I decided to review my Arabic
in depth and start to learn a Maghrebi
dialect then I think I would be able to
understand a lot more Maltese as well
Maltese is not a very widely spoken
language so not that many people learn
it and there aren't that many materials
out there for learners but for someone
who's learning Arabic or learning
Italian then it might be fun to dabble
in some Maltese and see what you can
make of it thank you for watching the
lang focused channel if you have any
comments about the Maltese language then
of course leave them in the comments
down below if you're an Arabic speaker
and you've had a chance to listen to
Maltese a little bit let us know what
you think can you understand it does it
sound like a kind of Arabic and same
goes for Italian speakers if you listen
to Maltese can you catch parts of what
they're saying let us know in the
comments down below we're getting close
to 50,000 subscribers online focus
that's quite cool I'm quite excited
about that but if I look at my social
media channels if I look at Facebook
Twitter and Instagram I noticed that I
still don't have that many followers so
be sure to have a look at those the link
is in the description down below and if
you find them interesting then be sure
to follow me there thank you for
watching and have a nice day